je suis revenu pour la première fois non
jamais si j'étais venu dans le jardin
j'avais emmené giulia sa fille mais je
n'étais pas rentré dans la maternité la
bri le parc il ya une petite église qui
datent du 12e siècle voilà le château de
bénouville ko we la maternité
il y a toujours d'ailleurs la maternité
avec des enfants qui naissent à tout
moment et qu'ils infirmières partout
c'est super estime c'est comme ça oui ça
fait que je suis plus est celle devant
le derrière du château enfin dijon de
cette huile devant c'est assez grand oui
il y avait des combles extraordinaire il
va un grenier ou montfrin mons perdait
on s'amuse on faisait face aux
infirmières
c'était toute une famille de maternité
de bénouville ci avait moment qui a été
sa muse femmes en chef
et puis qui a créé beaucoup de choses
enfin on aimait beaucoup ma mère vous
allez retrouver votre chambre vous au
lieu d'envoyer cinq ans j'ai dû passer
entre 80 et demi jusqu'à 5 sinon et
voilà c'est là où on habitait dans la
maternité
voilà la chambre c'est quand même
fantastique fait 30 ans puisse a pas
bougé je précisais même les en tout cas
le lit était là et c'est bon quand je
vois cette liste en rappel une image de
ma mère un cèpe temps j'ai eu la
diphtérie et puis j'étais très malade il
paraît j'ai failli mourir
et puis j'étais dans mon lit égyption
avec du sérum et je te fais sûrement
aller très mal et je me suis je me suis
réveillée une nuit je lui disais
gratte-moi les jambes parce que si on
m'avait gonflé comme ça les gens je vis
moment où qui pleurait comme sa fille
qui me grattais légende comme ça alors
là il ya la fenêtre et de la fenêtre on
voit le parc et pilar cela où j'allais à
l'école avec les enfants abandonnés que
les orphelins ils étaient tous en
petites capes noires avec des galoches
moi j'avais des chaussures en cuir comme
ça mais moi je voulais des galoches
j'avais été leur chiper les galoches des
galoches noir parce que ça faisait du
bruit sur la route
et puis quand on marchait sur la neige
comme ça on grandit c'est rien salle de
bains et une porte le supprimer ça
c'était ma chambre
ces mêmes portes
ah bah il y avait un lit mais plus qu'un
jeu couché là parce que quand on voit
quand j'étais malade c'était le leader
mans est sûr et puis on a eu sur la
terrasse
voilà c'est là où on allait à l'école
c'était c'était oui c'est l'école
c'était la cantine il y avait beaucoup
d'enfants abandonnés par les par leur
maman j'ai compris que moment était
sage-femme donc était interne dans cette
clinique dans cette maternité et
beaucoup de sage femme qui était tout
seul adoptez donc des petits camarades
de jeu à moi et je me souviens il y
avait un petit garçon qui s'appelle
petitjean et puis un autre qui était je
pense j'ai rien dans cette optique ou
frisés on l'appelait riri et puis un
autre qui s'appelait jean paul et puis
celle qui a eu jean paul elle a gardé
mes petits gens et riri ont disparu on
leur a retiré un jour on n'a pas voulu
qu'elle la doc je ne sais pas pourquoi
ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors on
allait tous ensemble à l'école avec les
six orphelins qui ont joué comme ça j'ai
des photos d'un vin dans cette prairie
élyséen très content comme ça et si je
retrouve la touche avant trop raide
tous ces enfants ont caché comme ça
parlait par les herbes la basse et le
pont de bénouville je sais pas si vous
voyez bien fameux bon de bénouville du
pont du débarquement
et puis ça c'est le canal et pierre le
long du canal à vous voyez le petit
chemin comme ça passé le petit train
pour le titre à départementale un tout
petit train comme ça sans s'en sont
paroisse en pensant fenêtre comme ça
souvent peu éventé et comment ils
allaient comme ça de ouistreham à la mer
de la mer à quand je sais que je suis
arrivé j'ai demandé à mon compte je me
souviens pas je suis arrivé ici j'avais
4 ans et demi fait pour n'a dû rester
2 ans de 3 ans jeudi au récit jusqu'à
l'âge de 2 septembre comme ça derrière
il ya un bois qui pour moi était une
forêt à exporter il y avait un arbre de
sang en immense qu'un jouet a été abattu
par l'afp
pour moi c'est une forêt immense
on se permet
j'ouvre les arbres sont au début mais
jamais que c'était lui si un jour il
faisait beaucoup de vent de j'ai eu
l'impression que j'allais m'en volets
étaient accrochés aux arbres
envoyez vos listes quand on est à la
vérité ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure on était bien parce qu'on est
tranquille on des peugeot
mais quand moment après on a vu une
maison elle était donc tout seul avec
ses deux enfants et mamans partait
quelques fois l'hiver à qu'il pleuve
qu'il vente qu'il neige
elle paraît sa voiture quelques fois à
40 km enfin 56 e mail à la guerre alors
on savait jamais d'ailleurs si on se
retrouvera d'ailleurs on ne pensait pas
je crois finalement et je me souviens de
deux nuits comme ça va c'est du vent
décide à beaucoup de vent et je couchais
avec moment rien n'a changé je couche
est toujours en cours et je me souviens
les nuits comme ça où le téléphone
sonnait grâce à cette offre il moment je
devais comme c'est que c'était bien
chaud dans le nickel on arrivait leveaux
qui fait 2 1
et puis moment se levait puis je
l'entendais oui oui
depuis combien de temps elle perd les
eaux et le fatidique
j'arrive
elle est inscrite ici le 2 octobre 1939
il en est reparti le 24 mars 1941 et
dans les registres d'appels
nous trouvons en 1939
annie girardot elle est inscrite sous le
nom d'anne je crois que c'était son
prénom son vrai prénom
je vois aussi annie girardot gentille
élèves intelligente
mehdi a fréquenté l'école trop peu et
trop tard
elle est partie comme une ville
c'est l'école sur lui un petit peu sage
aimait bien c'est utilisons n'a pas
bougé non plus le bureau de tabac des
cartes postales et c'est là que
j'achetais lisette les athées fillette
il y avait les athées fier de cette
époque donc à bâle puis donc ça c'est
l'entrée de l'usiné
avec toujours beaucoup si l'on entend
pas de sirène we have to journée ou pour
l'entrée ou à descendre de poussier ou
là on va voir la petite cahute là
c'était le l'arrêt du car là-bas le
voilà nous attend et on allait à caen à
l'école alors après la sinne square il y
avait un monsieur qui étaient gardés
jusqu'alors on l'appelait fou d'amour
qu'est ce qu'on a fait faire marcher le
pot pauvre fou d'amour alors notre
deuxième maison
cette et celtiques voilà si vous de
jardin qui est là on avait fait une
tranchée d'ailleurs formidable on joue
beaucoup
j'ai parce qu'on est obligés de faire
les tranchées est presque pas qu'ils
avaient n'existait pas oui c'était un
château d'eau qui a fait maison
alors on habitait là en haut à gauche
allons rentrer par cette petite chose
alors là c'était le salon je me souviens
avec le piano et puis on avait le phono
là avec les chansons de trenet j'avais
aussi une petite chambre qui était la
mienne où je rêvais je pense déjà à ce
moment là de faire du théâtre
et on domine quand
à l'époque on voyait toutes les flèches
de caen dans la nuit du 5 au 6 quand on
a compris qu'il y avait quelque chose
qui ne s'était pas
comme d'habitude alors l'âge comme on
l'a ou nam
on a vécu pendant deux jours on n'a plus
quitté la tranchée et puis après on est
descendu au grand de toute façon
vraiment et sans sage-femme et ayant à
travailler ne pouvait décemment pas
laisser ces d'enfance comme ça tout seul
là et en plus c'est pas de sécurité
c'est ce chemin là vous prenez pour
aller au vote qui descendait juste la
grotte nous étions réfugiés des votes
qui sauvait deux cas où finalement tout
aux populations de exactement oui avec
opérative état de choses comme ça et le
vin était en passe et là dedans
chez les dames qu à voir la neige est
une amie à nous
je tête j'avais elle avait une fille non
j'étais très ami avec sa fille avec une
autre petite fille les trois
inséparables et cette dame a été
accouchée justement par maman quelque
temps avant le débarquement a mis au
monde dans la grotte non non juste avant
la grotte et il ya eu elle le dira après
c'est madame vauthier est pour moi un
beauty ces mamies ceni non c'est c'est
encore une deuxième maman face et c'est
des choses très tendres et nous étions
un privilégié parce que nous étions dans
une grotte qui où il n'y avait sûrement
que 200 personnes mais d'autres
personnes dont madame vauthier
d'ailleurs le dire ah [ __ ] il ya les
personnes il y avait quelque chose 15
cents personnes 18 son percement faire
la vente pendant le débarquement de
normandie
on a vécu il faut dire que colomb l
usine de co2 quand enfin et sur un
plateau est évidemment sous le plateau
il ya des grottes appelé les roches et
c'est là que 8000 personnes en véhicule
serieys beaucoup beaucoup de grottes et
celle ci fait partie de ces grottes mans
évidemment elle est un peu plus petit on
était un peu privilégié moment elle
exerçait enfin le continuer sa
profession de sage-femme dire qu'elle
convient lamy au mot les enfants du
monde dans les grottes
pendant ces sept semaines survient la
femme qui était en douleur alors on lit
les halls isoler on tenait les
couvertures comme ça avec quatre
personnes et va j'ai tenu couverture ils
ont trait couverture et la faire avec ce
n'est une lampe à carbure à mon éthique
est par exemple car de 50 mg valores pas
car je sais rien
alors on avait de l'eau à peu près
le creux de demain pour la toilette de
l'enfant et de la maman
et quand on portait les enfants au jour
pour la première fois quand même content
entendu porté au jour il avait les
narines c'était 2 qui chemine et plein
de suie à cause de la poussière de la
fumée tarbes sûrs que nous que nous
respirions
voiliers fait malherbe
évidemment qu est ce qui reste de grands
vins c'est ça le palais de justice et le
lycée malherbe église saint-pierre
surtout que tout le reste finissant
connaître
on apprend la rue froide a mis quelque
chose à roanne
d
e
et
alors si iggy pop y avait tellement je
dis plus quelques c'est celle ci c'est
saint pierre ce qu'elle est bonne
m
belle bête et clochers
hu
oh